[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today hawking radiation
our universe is modeled by two theories
general relativity which describes the
fabric of the universe as a smooth
surface that can bend
space-time and quantum field theory
which describes particles as small
packets of energy
inside quantum fields
these two theories work extremely well
and model almost
everything we know in their respective
fields
but unfortunately they are currently
irreconcilable
calculations fail to describe the
microscopic origin of gravity
the way in which particles discrete
packets of energy
can bend a continuous surface like
space-time
still it remains possible to study the
behavior of quantum particles inside a
curved space-time
if we suppose it to be fixed neglecting
the fact that the particles
should influence its curvature
it's with an ingenious calculation of
this type then in 1974 stephen hawking
came across an astonishing phenomenon
hawking discovers that black holes
produce a subtle radiation
which eventually causes them to
evaporate a phenomenon mixing gravity
and quantum physics
hawking radiation
a black hole is a spherical region
a space-time bubble bounded by a horizon
within which gravity is so intense
that nothing can escape
when surrounded by mata black holes
radiate and can be detected from earth
however this radiation is indirect it
comes from the matter
outside the black hole the black hole
itself
is not really an object but rather a
region
it should not radiate near the horizon
space is empty
however we should not forget about
quantum physics
according to quantum physics our
universe contains
fields which fill all space and are
present everywhere
even in what we call the vacuum
quantum fields are agitated by
fluctuations
they contain waves called virtual
particles
some with positive energy and others
with negative
energy the vacuum
in quantum field theory is simply the
state in which these positive and
negative waves
compensate each other the fluctuations
are still present but nothing propagates
in the field
a real particle is a wave which is not
cancelled out
and thus propagates
[Music]
back to relativity the natural movement
of bodies in space-time is free-fall
the fabric of the universe is curved and
objects tend to move straight ahead
causing them to fall
[Music]
we can represent the curvature around a
black hole by a grid which contracts
over time
an object at rest remains either
stationary or at constant speed
relative to this grid
conversely an object wanting to oppose
the natural movement of the grid
is forced to exert an acceleration
against freefall
locally space-time seems flat the
curvature is only visible on a large
scale
as on earth
[Music]
therefore an observer in freefall does
not see anything special
and in particular she does not feel
anything weird when crossing the horizon
of a black hole
we have seen that the space around the
black hole is empty
and this is true in particular near the
horizon
quantum field theory describes a vacuum
as a balance of positive and negative
waves
these waves are defined on the
space-time grid
they are in a natural state and a
free-falling observer
does not detect any particles she does
indeed see
a vacuum
but now imagine an observer who remains
parked
just above the horizon
to avoid falling this observer is forced
to constantly accelerate
but because he accelerates relative to
the grid he perceives the waves
differently
by accelerating with respect to these
waves he receives them with distorted
frequencies
in particular the waves under the
horizon never reach the observer who
accelerates away
[Music]
the person in free fall does not detect
the horizon of the black hole
for her the horizon is a place like any
other and the positive and negative
waves cancel each other
the space is empty
but the person who prevents himself from
falling does
detect the horizon because he
accelerates such that
some waves never reach him for him
the positive and negative waves do not
cancel
from this point of view space is not
empty
it is filled with particles
[Music]
it is crucial to understand that the
notions of vacuum
and particles are relative
because they move differently in space
time the two observers see the
fluctuations in quantum fields
differently
whilst one sees a vacuum the other sees
particles
near the horizon we cannot say whether
there are particles or not
in absolute terms this notion
is relative the existence of these
particles depends
on the observer
[Music]
until now our reasoning was only local
the notion of particles
is relative as soon as we have an
observer who accelerates whether we are
next to a black hole or in an empty
space-time
but in our case space-time is curved on
a large scale
and while the notion of particles is
purely relative near the horizon
the further we move away from the black
hole the more
staying still which is an accelerated
movement near the horizon
becomes the natural movement
these particles which exist in a
relative way near the horizon
gradually become real particles as they
move away from the black hole
thus black holes radiate this is hawking
radiation
the virtual particles near the horizon
become real particles
far away the curvature of space-time
makes the transition between a region
where we need to accelerate to remain
motionless
and a region where being motionless is
natural
we understand that this radiation does
not escape from inside the black hole
nothing comes out the particles we
detect far away
originate in the quantum fluctuations
just outside the horizon
an intuitive way of interpreting this
phenomenon is to imagine the vacuum
as a soup of virtual particles which
appear in pairs
one of positive energy the other of
negative energy
and immediately annihilate
[Music]
usually these virtual particles cannot
become real particles
they remain undetectable especially
because a real particle must necessarily
have
positive energy these pairs of virtual
particles
one which has a negative energy must
therefore disappear
[Music]
but inside a black hole the curvature is
so intense
that the notions of time and space are
reversed
from an external point of view this
allows the particles
inside the black hole to have a negative
energy
when a virtual pair appears on the
horizon the negative particle thus has a
chance to exist
if it is captured by the black hole it
is now allowed to become
a real particle while the positive
particle can escape
away
by absorbing these negative particles
the black hole loses
more and more energy and little by
little
hawking radiation makes black holes
evaporate
hawking radiation is what we call a
thermal radiation
its spectrum matches perfectly the
spectrum that an object would emit
due to its temperature
we can thus assign a temperature to
black holes corresponding to the energy
of their radiation large black holes
are very cold because at their horizon
the curvature is very mild
they evaporate very slowly
[Music]
and the smaller a black hole the more
energetic
its radiation corresponding to a high
temperature
[Music]
this is a very peculiar property of
black holes
usually when a body radiates energy
its temperature decreases
but a black hole that radiates shrinks
and its temperature rises by losing
energy
black holes heat up and the evaporation
accelerates
more and more
having said that all known black holes
weigh several billions of billions of
billions of tons
since they form in the collapse of
massive stars
their radiation is extremely weak its
temperature reaches
at most a few billionth of a degree
above absolute zero
and it consists only of massless
particles such as photons
the evaporation is thus completely
negligible
it would take several thousands of
billions of billions of billions of
billions of billions of billion times
the age of the universe
to watch them evaporate
furthermore the universe is filled with
radiation from the big bang
the cosmic microwave background
absorbing this radiation
black holes in reality grow bigger
if the energy of this microwave
background decreases
as the universe expands the evaporation
might take over
but we would have to wait several
hundred billion years
however there could potentially exist
small primordial black holes
formed just after the big bang whose
evaporation
could be ongoing right now we hope that
their radiation
could one day be detected
for the moment hawking radiation remains
a theoretical result
it is currently impossible to detect and
based on an approximation
neglecting the effect of particles on
the geometry of space-time
we will certainly have to wait for a
real theory of quantum gravity
to understand this phenomenon with
precision in particular
the last instance of the evaporation
when the radiation is most intense
still it is a very solid prediction
many different calculations lead to
these same conclusions
in 1974 hawking calculated the
gravitational collapse of a star and how
the formation of the black hole
affects the quantum fields
a more abstract method is to study time
not as a real number but as an imaginary
number
this is a technique from statistical
physics the imaginary time
loops back on itself and we recover the
black hole's temperature
from the length of these loops
experimentally we already studying the
phenomenon using analogies
in particular we can create a flow of
fluid in the lab
that mimics the conditions of a black
hole with a sort of horizon
that separates a supersonic flow from a
slower flow
on one side sound waves can escape
and on the other side since the fluid is
faster they are captured
these analogies are not perfect but the
equations that describe them
are close to those of the true
phenomenon and several
experiments have led to promising
results
hawking's calculations and the research
that followed
helped bridge the gap between
gravitation and quantum physics
opening the first paths towards a
unification
of the two realms for the first time
a formula that of the temperature of a
black hole
involved all the constants of modern
physics
bringing together relativity gravitation
quantum physics and thermodynamics
the evaporation of black holes raises
many questions and leads to paradoxes in
our current understanding of physics
usually in physics knowing its final
state
it's possible in theory to deduce the
initial state of a system
but two perfectly identical black holes
might have formed from two different
stars
and after they evaporate there would be
no traces left
of what happened
this is the information paradox
the information of what was captured by
a black hole
seems to be lost forever once it
evaporates
perhaps this information remains at the
horizon
and is captured and taken away as
hawking radiation escapes
or maybe the black hole doesn't totally
disappear
and leaves a tiny remnant that holds all
the information
at the moment we still don't know
finally in recent years hawking
radiation has helped highlight an even
stronger
paradox linked to the fact that the
virtual particles which separate at the
horizon
should remain entangled forever this
paradox brings out the limits of our
current models
of which some principles might have to
be abandoned
in the hope of one day finding a theory
of everything
one approach to solving this problem is
to abandon
the equivalence principle which says
that nothing special happens at the
horizon
some believe that there might be a
mechanism that somehow violently breaks
the entanglement between the escaping
particle and the unfalling one
a sort of firewall
[Music]
you